Hello everyone, today's concepts
and context lesson is going to
be pretty brief, but I want
to really dive into references
specifically because self-referencing,
like I talked about in the
welcome video for this week, is
one of those things that you're
going to find yourself using
over and over no matter the field
you're in, no matter what you're
trying to leverage Excel to do.
So I want to walk through this
a lot more in depth. And so
what we'll be doing is we're
going to set up a spreadsheet
that has one through six up
here and then one ten, one
hundred, one thousand, all the
way up to is that one million?
Yep, I have one million there
because I want you to be able
to see how these different
things are working. So when
you really dive into it and
you're thinking, what cells do
I need to walk into place or
make an absolute reference,
then we understand how this
is working a little bit more.
So first things first,
what I'm going to do
is in C3, I am just
going to create a simple
calculation using C1
or C2 multiplied by B3.
And you'll notice this is one of
my favorite things about Excel. is
that C2 is blue and you'll notice
that cell here is also highlighted
blue and B3 is red and is also
highlighted red here. So when you
click double click into a calculated
field you can really quickly see
what cells are being pulled in to
get that answer. So it makes sense
one times one is in fact one so now
when I click on this I'm not double
clicking I'm just single clicking
and I get a little green box that
gets pulled up now what I can do is
I can hover over this little green
square right here and see how my mouse
turns into a little crosshair I can
take this and drag it across and
now you'll see that my calculations
have been dragged over and you'll
see depending on how we thought about
this maybe some unexpected results so
I'm going to do the same thing here
I'm going to click in C3 I'm going
to hold my mouse right mouse down
and highlight that whole row so now
what I can do is when my crosshairs
show up I can either click this
little button which is an autofill
option I can double click and that
drags information down as well or
I could just drag as many as I want
and I just take control Z just to
go back a few steps.
So all these will function
the same. So let's click into,
let's say, F4 here. So when
I click on this, you'll
see that to create this
calculation, I'm using F3 and E4.
So this is a calculation based off
of this calculation based on this
calculation. and that all makes
sense that's fine but it may not be
what we expected it to happen so
when I drag my formula over and I
don't have any dollar signs or absolute
references here what is happening
is that my formula moves over
the same number of cells that I
dragged it to So if you come way
down here to H9, you'll see this is
H8 times G9 because it moved in
relation to the new cell. So C2 is up
one and B3 is over one. And so
that's exactly what this formula did.
It's going to reference the cell
right above it and the cell right
to the left of it in order to
generate these numbers. but let's say
I want to lock these numbers in place
meaning I want to only reference
one so when I move it over I'm
not moving it with me so I'm going
to lock my column in place and then
multiply that by the row up top.
So now when I do this and I click,
you'll see that I didn't
move my blue square with
me. It stayed right here
and it went over. So now I'm
one up top, but I'm still
referencing the column B.
Now, based on this, as I drag
this formula down to the next row,
pause for a second and
see if you can think
about your output that
you're going to get.
So when I drag this down, I'm
going to get 10, 20, 30, 40,
50, 60, because I only locked
the column in place here.
so it moved down but you'll notice
my row and I'm referencing right
above it so I'm still referencing
one above and as I drag it over I
have my B column still locked into
place but I don't have a dollar sign
in front of the number so it's
only going to continue to reference
the B column, but it'll move down the
row with me as I drag my row down.
So now let's delete that back out.
Now what would happen if I locked
both B and 3 into place and then
multiplied it by C2 without any absolute
references being locked in there.
So I'm going to do the same
thing I'm going to drag it across
the row and you'll see that you
know it looks exactly like it did
before but where it's going to
change now is when I drag it
down and I click I'm still referencing
the cell right above that's
that e4 with the red but because
I locked both the column and
the row into place I'm only
referencing b3 so that number no
matter how far I drag this formula
is going to stay right here.
Now we can look at this really quick
the other way where we only have
three locked in and we can drag that
down and we're back to a similar
one that we started with but as you
click on these numbers you'll see that
it's the column is moving so it's
still only one column to the right
left of this because that's what we
specified but it's staying on row
three so that's getting locked into
place and last but not least what
happens if we start locking in all of
these numbers so if we do two absolute
references with both the number
and the column for both parts of
this calculation, take a second
before you start dragging your formula
around, take a second to see if you
know what is going to show up in h9.
It's going to stay one,
because there's no movement
happening. When we get
rid of our dollar signs,
that is where movement happens
in relation to where we've
moved to the formula. So this
is just a quick example. I'll
have some questions down below
just for you to answer to see
if you really or conceptually
getting what the dollar sign
is doing. We're locking in the
value. So as we fill a formula
down, we're referencing the
fields we expect to reference.
So go ahead, take a break from this,
and then answer those questions.
And as always, let me know what
questions you have as I'm here to help.